you and your friends are stuck on a
deserted island with giant murderous
bugs hunting you down all these
monstrous little insects want to do is
to hunt you for sports drain your blood
and eat you alive what do you do i'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat every
killer bug in the island of giant
insects okay okay this girl here is a
high school student her name is mutsumi
and she wakes up disoriented on a
deserted beach and realizes that her
plane crashed well that sucks but
doesn't seem like anybody else survived
she panics grabs her bag and takes up
into the woods okay don't do this
tropical forests contain dangerous
wildlife predators poisonous plants and
disco doesn't even have a plan to build
a shelter
the safest bet would be to go back to
the crash site to look for resources
cause that's smart especially bottled
water a human can survive for weeks
without food but they'll die within
three days without any water so you need
water considering that there were not
many people aborting this flight in the
first place we can assume there's gonna
be leftover bottles around the plain
ruins i would also keep an eye out and
search these bags for dry clothes and
for any kind of sharp object as she's
running into the woods like a headless
chicken because stupid she's stopped by
this girl ayumi who goes to her school
they reunite oh good we have friends
again and the girl tells her that she
looked around but the island seems
deserted yeah no kidding she did find a
lighter a knife and a bottle of
hairspray these are gonna come in handy
later but something is clearly wrong
mutsumi here mentions that this force is
deadly quiet okay this is really unusual
since there are in the middle of a
jungle howler monkeys and birds make
some of the loudest noises you telling
me they aren't hearing a single frog
cicada or even a damn bird or monkey
what these two should be swarmed by
wildlife and insects and all the nasty
critters that i just love avoiding but
it's dead quiet spooky but if we're not
hearing any sounds it means there's
something wrong with this ecosystem
worse yet their phones are soaked so
they have no way to communicate with the
outside world or with each other and
with them being high school students i
won't expect them to be able to build a
radio anytime soon with the supplies
available okay these two suddenly hear a
scream in the distance and rush towards
the sound they reach this field and see
two giant butterflies flying over them
you thinking oh cool great they're
butterflies cute and cuddly giant
butterflies and they're huge problem
these flying nightmares are preying on
this girl and are in the process of
draining her blood and i'd be like okay
let's leave but that's not enough these
two schoolgirls realize insects are
still hungry after finishing their meal
and are moving on to their next victim
hope it's not me okay this is terrifying
this bug has sucked the blood out of my
friends and it's not even done the
smallest mistake here will be fatal and
if i want to beat it i need to know
everything about it this butterfly is
huge it's probably like the size of a
freaking helicopter but we can assume
that it will have the same behaviors and
features as a normal-sized butterfly
where i would squash it with my hands
butterflies are able to detect ground
vibrations caused by mammals they also
have many eyes in two main spots that
give them a wide field of vision and
they feed exclusively on liquids and
uses their senses to smell nectar or in
this case blood and sweat if it's me i'm
realizing here that i can't defeat this
monster without a weapon even if i'm
going to take the risk with what i had
which is nothing there's no hope for
these people anyways so i'm slowly
backing away from the scene to avoid
creating any large vibrations in the air
and would use the water i had saved from
the crash site because i am smart and
not dumb like them and mix it with dirt
to make a paste and cover myself this
way i will hide my scent to avoid their
smell detection of me and allow me to
escape to a safe place assuming i find
one but ayumi here decides to rush in
like captain america with a freaking
knife and tries to stop the butterfly
which fails quickly and somehow
miraculously misumi here lights the
lighter and sprays the hairspray in the
direction of butterfly she sets it on
fire and the butterfly burns to death
while the other one flies away well pull
up the fire on that hairspray look at
that thing that's not realistic at all
you have a tiny spray can and it put out
a flame enough to cover the size of a
helicopter-sized butterfly right about
now it should be clear that there's
something clearly wrong with this island
and i would want to leave and staying in
the woods was not safe the idea to burn
the butterfly was great not realistic
but good for them and it actually worked
but they should definitely be heading to
the beach now which they don't or at the
very least since butterflies are the
lowest part of the food chain and we've
just killed a giant butterfly i'm taking
any body part i can from the dead insect
to use as bait and also maybe a armor a
while later our mutsumi girl groups up
with more students yay more people to
use as meat shields so i don't die and
explains they should wait for the
self-defense force to find and save them
the group then hears the noise of a
helicopter they start running towards it
but they're wrong again a giant killer
wasp appears in their path and this one
is much much scarier than the
butterflies they've just escaped from
this time it's a mud wasp so you're in
for a real sting get it mud anyways
they're called mud wasps because they
use wet mud to make their nests and
right about now i'm wishing i kept a
piece of those butterflies but they
didn't because butterflies are one of
their main prey and the bait would have
made for a great distraction they have
super strong jaws that they use for
biting and cutting and the female wasp
carries a stinger that they can use over
and over it's not like a b where they
both they sting you and then they die
nope they can use it over and over the
only thing we've got going for us is
that they are loud if we successfully
distract them with uh
friends i'm getting away and keeping my
ears open to the sound of wings flapping
if there is none that means there's
either no wasp in the area or i got
distracted by something else whatever
the reason i'm taking this chance to
amps gray and get away as soon as
possible unfortunately for the group
this wasp is way too fast for the group
and takes hold of chitose here the poor
girl gets stung with a paralyzing agent
and is taken away by the murder bug and
of course argo mitsumi here convinces
the group to rescue chitose okay we can
assume here that jotosa is good is dead
going after her makes no sense like what
are you doing no excuse is good enough
to make me go inside a wasp nest unless
i drop a bomb on it then sure i would
leave her behind these kids need to
learn to cut their losses like big time
and make hard decisions in order to
survive but since the group has decided
to follow the wasps back to their nest
oh goody for them i would at least wait
until night time because that makes more
sense when these wasps are less
aggressive we want to minimize the sound
and avoid alerting the wasps so i would
only send two people into the nest and
if i had to go i would quickly find him
and get out asap but mitsumi reveals a
massive advantage she apparently knows
quite a bit about insects that would've
been great to know in the beginning and
she so proves why she's at the top of my
totem pole of stay friends with her
until we get off this island by using
her insect knowledge to lead the group
to the wasp's nest somehow this crazy
redhead is not happy with that because
she is
attention because mutsumi is stealing
all the attention which she should cause
she's smart and shows us that she's the
character that we want to get dead they
arrive at what looks like a village and
they find out that these houses have
become nests for the killer wasps and
they're about to seriously regret this
decision okay okay this girl clearly
knows what she's talking about so maybe
we should just follow her and if i'm on
this island i'm not letting her involve
my set remember hi i'm the totem pole of
keep her on my friend's list anyways her
knowledge can help us survive until we
get some real help and stay away from
the crazy redhead the crazy redhead is
making a big mistake by complaining so
loudly right now we need to listen to
misumi and use her as a resource she's
like a prophet sent from god out of the
heavens the group walks into the nest
and find their friends being in alive by
gigantic larva and the larva are
releasing a pleasure chemical to keep
their friends from escaping man this is
dirty these three start beating the
larva to bits they run out of the house
and mutsumi here is hoping they'll go to
save her friend but the rest of the
group wants to leave her for dead as
they're about to leave another murder
wasp appears oh great another one
carrying a friend of this delinquent
here he runs after it and almost ends up
getting killed well these larva may not
look cute but they're still babies and
their only power is a pleasure chemical
that they inject into the paralyzed
people and that sounds really bad the
wasps bring the people so that the larva
can feed and grow nasty these larva are
the size of a person's hand really gross
and they're sucking onto my friends like
leeches oh man now they're gonna die but
if i want to get out of here quickly i
don't want to take the time to rip them
off of him so i'm gonna leave them on my
friend here sorry my priority is
escaping this place in one piece the
good thing about these larva is that
they are edible larvae sushi anyone oh
gosh what if that's a real thing wasp
larvae are considered a delicacy in
japan if you didn't know and i didn't
know that was a real thing they're fat
and filled with protein right now since
they've been feeding on my friend that's
morbid we need food to survive and if we
take a handful we'll have plenty food to
keep us alive mutsumi here makes an
escape plan and goes into the nest with
the delinquent guy they both managed to
find their friends and i'm like yay good
for them but this guy decided he's
leaving the two girls behind in the
meantime ayumi is outside emptying
bottles of cosmetics on the house she's
doing that because wasps are naturally
attracted to the smell of hair and skin
products due to the alcoholic and esters
composition that is similar to their
hormones so basically if you smell
really good or really bad then they go
after you anyways the wasps come rushing
into the nest because of the smell and
are too focused on the scent to care
about the teens ayumi and the teens hide
in the bushes while the other four are
still stuck inside this delinquent guy
escapes but ayumi has to go back in to
help carry chitose thankfully they make
it out alive okay i would have done the
same thing that this guy here did if
there's a bunch of wasps coming after me
i'm leaving everybody behind his bait
and running for my life there's no way
i'm staying to help someone that has
very limited chances of survival using
the skin care products to distract the
wasps is a very smart idea but ayumi
should have been more careful she could
have accidentally sprayed herself with
this game product which would have been
the last mistake of her life attracting
the wasp to her and the rest of the
group she'd be much better pouring out
the cosmetics instead of spraying them
that way i won't risk getting it caught
in the wind and getting it on myself the
group then looks for a hospital on this
tourist signboard that they find near
the village they're in need of sailing
solution to treat chitose here and the
delinquent guy's friend but the
hospital's far away and the sun's going
down alright this map is exactly what we
need have like great we found one
there's no better time than now to get
out of the woods and back into the beach
area we have a working phone so we can
snap a picture of this map and use it as
we're walking towards the hospital
cheetos and the other guys are simply
paralyzed so we're not risking their
lives by taking a longer way so far
we've only found that these bugs are in
the woods and it's unlikely they'll be
out and about on the beach side as
they're walking through the woods they
enter a nest of hard ticks and they're
the size of a golf ball these bugs are
getting worse and worse we've got to
deal with huge ticks now these bugs
latch on and suck on a person's blood
while leaking poisons into the body that
can kill them they survive for years
without any food and with this island
being deserted they must be starving all
my greats have all my friends but please
let me go now keeping on this path is
going to get us killed these blood
sucking bugs are blind so i'm slowly
backtracking and getting out of their
territory as long as they don't notice
us we will be able to escape and make it
out of this alive though blind ticks
have heightened senses they can hear the
smallest vibration so i would take
musumi's hat or a rock or something and
throw it as far away from the group as
possible that way i'm the hero this will
attract the attention of the bugs and we
will be able to run away the group walks
slowly through the path until they meet
a teacher who's already infested with
ticks in order to save the entire group
our guru mitsumi pushes the teacher and
the ticks attack her mutsumi and the
others managed to get out of the woods
that night mutsumi tells the girls to
submerge themselves in the spring water
this will make the ticks leave the body
because they need oxygen to survive this
mutsumi is a real wonder she cries every
time she kills a bugging yet she has no
remorse for killing another human being
i would reconsider my priorities but i'm
definitely not getting on her bad side
getting in the water is one of the
safest things these girls could have
done i would also check my body
afterwards to make sure that the ticks
are all gone from my body if they're not
i'm getting back into the water for as
long as it takes but they're nowhere
near safe well these two are getting
distracted big trouble is coming for
this guy something's entered his body
and it's wriggling through his veins and
it's about to make this situation a
whole lot worse these two are too busy
to notice
what's going on if it's me i'm leaving
this guy behind he's already caused
enough drama in the group and he's not
even conscious we don't have the tools
to remove the parasite and there's no
point in putting everyone in danger just
to save one man after getting dry and
doing the dirty the people finally
arrive at the hospital area mutsumi
doesn't hear any creatures and the group
is relieved to me too this geeky guy
right here has found a very interesting
room there's a working computer system
in this room which means that they
should be able to contact someone
outside of this island he mentions that
there's no connection but that's fixable
the generator still works and we can
control the lighting with the computers
the plane that these high schoolers were
on crashed on this specific island which
means there's a high chance that it was
on the plane route planes flied all
times of the day so i would wait until
night time and keep a lookout for
anything in the sky as soon as i spot a
plane i'm going to signal sos and morse
code through these light poles outside
if i use the generator energy only for
this the battery is going to last long
enough to get help mutsumi here and the
delinquent guy quickly give the saline
solution to their unconscious friend and
wait for a reaction while these guys are
busy focusing on chitose they don't
notice that this parasite is starting to
move on this guy's forehead suddenly the
guy they saved starts moving around the
parasite that entered his body has taken
over control and he's gone mad oh and
did i all mention the guy's eyeballs are
bulging out and now it's too late to get
the parasite out of him this is a green
banded brute sack and it's known for
feeding off of its host it's usually
found in snails and it invades their
antenna changing their colors to make it
look like caterpillars this attracts the
attention of birds who eat the snails
and the parasite if it's me i'm taking
this can of tuna and smashing it on the
guy's head we cannot allow him to get
outside because he'll put us all in
danger there's no hope for this guy and
we quickly have to decide how to get rid
of him if it's me i'm getting the geeky
guy to bring me a wire from the computer
room then i'm using it to choke that
out of this guy this guy runs outside
and climbs the light pole like a
freaking spider-man he's calling the
attention of another giant bug and right
on time this creepy dobson fly comes
flying in okay we know that this
hospital is located close to a lake
which happens to be where dobson flies
live most of them are found in flowing
rivers and close to lakes and hiding
among rocks just like every other fly
this creepy bug is attracted to lights
dobson flies have short legs and four
huge wings they also have really long
antennas that they use to sense their
prey since they're nocturnal animals
they rely on their antennas to hunt this
bug is hard to kill but we already know
its weakness the antenna are very
sensitive to any kind of movement i
would distract it by having three or
four people run around and taking turns
and making loud noise because i am that
good at manipulating people i would go
back inside and look for tools to start
a fire the simplest things that we can
use are this tunican battery and piece
of aluminum foil tunicans usually
contain oil so i can use that to act as
fuel i would then take off my shirt and
show off my six pack i'm kidding and
drench it in the tuna can i would remove
the battery from my phone and roll up a
small piece of aluminum foil that i took
from the emergency rations then i would
form the foil into a u-shape and go
outside i would put the drenched shirt
on the floor and set it on fire by
placing the foil on the battery's
positive and negative terminals mutsumi
tells them to go back inside but they're
not listening as the red head pulls a
delinquent away the bug flies straight
into parasite guy and kills him the
monster fly then goes after the rest of
the group alright parasite guy is dead
good and we need to run fast the door is
not too far away which means that we can
reach it in time to shut the bug out we
already know it's attracted to lights so
i would tell the geeky guy to shut the
whole building down if it's dark and we
sit still the bug won't be able to sense
or see us and will leave us all alone
and hopefully we all live the groups
start running back to the building but
the redhead and the delinquent lock
everyone outside with the excuse that
they may be infected as well oh
now that's a shitty move and a stupid
one too these two can't survive on their
own they're not strong enough and smart
enough they meet our resident expert
mutsumi to help them out and if it's me
i'm letting them in if they're so scared
about these three being affected they
can easily tie them up and make sure
they can't escape but since they have no
intention of doing so we need to find a
way to break in the glass on this door
is not very thick which means we can
break it with a sharp object ayumi here
has already found a rock and i know what
you're thinking but banging it that way
is not very effective i would aim at the
hinges and the corners of the door
because they're the weakest part and
easiest to break the best way to hit
this glass is to take the pointy part of
the rock take a couple of steps back and
run with full force on the door this
will create a small crack that i can
widen by banging on it more but this
would create another issue because now
the bug can enter the building
thankfully there's plenty of rooms that
we can lock ourselves in and we have
enough water to survive this bug will
eventually get tired of looking for us
and will eventually abandon the building
these girls are freaking out this bug is
going to kill them any minute now and
i'm kind of like yes just get it over
with unexpectedly this geeky guy shows
up and opens the door just as they're
about to get murdered good for them he's
tied up these two losers and is now
cooperating with the rest of the group
it's time to kill this creepy bug before
it gets a chance to kill anyone else
mutsumi figures out a way to outsmart it
she takes curtains from every room and
ties them around this light pole she
then catches the attention of the bug
with a sound device and makes it come
all the way to the pole as soon as the
fly is close enough she pulls the
curtains to reveal that the light has
been turned on the bug immediately flies
towards the light when it arrives
mutsumi signals the rest of the group
the geeky guy blasts the generator power
on the pole burning the dobson flat to
ashes yes that was very satisfying later
the group goes back to the hospital
where they collect all the rations this
girl chitose is declared leader and they
decide to stay in the building until
help arrives okay this is so weird
chitose is literally like been m.i.a for
most of it but what do you think how
would you beat the island of giant
insects
well that was intense hey guys griffin
here from how to beat anime thank you so
much for checking out our video and our
channel if you liked the video please
leave a big thumbs up subscribe buttons
right there hit it please because we're
desperate and let us know what you
thought about the video but be nice okay
cuz i'm a sensitive so not really but
let us know what you like okay
have a good one